this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description
mrna vaccines for covid19
vaccines are substances that protect you
from harmful diseases
most vaccines contain parts of weakened
or dead germs that
trigger your immune system to fight the
disease but
mrna vaccines for covenanting are
different
they contain a substance called mrna
that teaches your cells how to make a
protein that triggers an immune response
in order to understand how these
vaccines work it's important to know
what mrna is
and how it normally makes proteins your
body needs
most cells in your body have a command
center inside them called
the nucleus it contains genetic material
called dna that consists of instructions
for building and maintaining your body
proteins are one of the building blocks
of your body
when a new body protein needs to be
built instructions for building it are
copied from your cell's dna
and converted into a message called
messenger rna
or mrna then the mrna travels out of the
nucleus to a protein-building machine in
your cell
called a ribosome as the ribosome
reads the message from the mrna it
builds the protein your body needs
mrna vaccines take advantage of this
process to help give you
immunity to coven 19. each vaccine
contains special mrna
that provides instructions for your
cells to build a harmless piece of the
virus
called the spike protein the spike
protein is found on the surface of the
sars cov2 coronavirus that causes
covid19
each piece of the mrna from the vaccine
is wrapped in a protective coating
the vaccine is given as a shot in the
upper arm
in the body the mrna particles enter
your cells
once inside the cell the mrna travels to
a ribosome
using the mrna from the vaccine the
ribosome makes only a piece of the spike
protein from the virus
after making the piece of the spike
protein your cell destroys the mrna from
the vaccine
it's important to know that the mrna
from the vaccine
never enters the cell's nucleus or
changes its dna
in any way next
your cell presents the piece of the
spike protein on its surface
this allows your immune cells to detect
the protein
and recognize that it doesn't belong
there
as a result your immune cells begin
making antibodies as part of an immune
response to the virus
in the future if you catch the virus the
antibodies recognize
and attach to the spike protein pieces
on infected cells
and the spike proteins on the virus this
marks them for immediate destruction by
other immune cells
like all vaccines the benefit of these
mrna vaccines is that they give
vaccinated people protection from the
virus
without having to get sick with covet
19.
most mrna vaccines for covid19 require
you to get a second shot within a few
weeks
sometime after getting the vaccine you
may have symptoms such as a fever
this is normal it means the vaccine is
working to make you immune to the virus
vaccines protect you your family and
your community from diseases that can be
dangerous
or even deadly for up-to-date
information about vaccines for covet-19
visit the centers for disease control
and prevention website at cdc.gov